bois guarín e james
ele
vem
efe
hurd
o cérebro chan
lá eu as cidades ligadas a perna boa
olá eu sou o conflito enquanto está
tratado microfone aqui a já há aqui uma
e ter baile chantal de encontrá-la estou
por 1 a 0 sobre o rico e eu sou
convidada travesso iremos falar de share
evolução hora saiu este conceito de
evolução de partilhar e evoluir com essa
partida é uma coisa que é por menos
pra nós a nossa geração é uma coisa
muito intrínseco em nós muito primária
como vocês puderam ver foi exposta na
cabeça desde animation fazem uma fusão
significa vão ser colocados mais forte
mas quem diz dragon ball deste tipo para
rezas dos cantos roubou juntavam todos
fazem um robô mas fora de série evolução
em e ao longo da nossa vida vamos
aplicando este conceito nas várias
coisas fomos fazendo exatamente nós como
youtuber sendo sem os habituais muito é
que de partilha força ao méxico para nós
é como tu vai se preservar os nossos
conteúdos na comunidade do youtube
as pessoas que vão ver os vídeos partir
de hoje vem se tornando cada vez mais
visitas e mais partilha depois entrar
num ciclo vicioso
nós todos participamos no vídeo de um
amigo nosso
o saque é e eu vou explicar isso porque
os titulares criaram um conceito novo de
colégio e fazemos operações em um ou
mais 8 bits
participam num vídeo e o que significou
dizendo neste caso do do evento destaque
é que no final deste vídeo todas as
visualizações foram muito maiores e
verificamos que conseguiu fechar os
subscritores do candidato cada um
profissional dos outros giros
vamos ver não temos um querendo evento
está aqui para mostrar o exato
dentro do santa cândida em dia já tem
alguns não existem muitos de 2011 22
eu ainda não tinha barulho mas eu já
aprendi a montagem também não estamos
aqui para melhor peça foi o papel do
futungo de belas corridas de táxi norte
informações pedindo informações sobre o
que estavam fazendo uma semana rússia
espiritual
acho que lá está o papel do estudo
treinar falar aqui é mais encontrado de
tinga só então foi com ele pegasse um
escritor
igual muito forte
ae olha o meu lado e falou que não
queria falar em não sair era um local
também ficou acertado nenhum veto
é isso aí uns certeza vai estar aqui nós
participamos não é exato e depois não
durou muito a aplicar-se na nossa vida
real é os agentes o conceito de cada um
juntar os seus mundos é nesta altura
isso aqui foi uma escola e em viseu
escola secundária de viriato em 2011
foi uma altura inclusive que o escutavam
ser chamado suprir as listas todos os
casos em que as listas das pessoas
diante sim ea mata todas juntas para
fazer uma mega festa durante a semana na
escola e entrou eu eo nero na altura em
2011 ainda não tinha entanto as
visualizações e ele estava cansado no
mundo
o nero que já tinha popularidade já
tenho mas não estava muito organizar
aquela cena de escolas mas eu amava não
é não gostar eu tinha 16 anos
15 não é fácil ganhar é organizar e das
escolas e transferências bancárias
locações também da casa tocar no rio com
que te digo uma pessoa tem um gps
europeu sabe sim os autocarros maneira o
convite estava os autocarros da manhã em
cuidar dessa parte chata da produção e
da comunicação é então o produto o der
não gostava muito dessa porta organizado
mas tinha 200 peito eo técnico
facilidade em organizar esses pedidos
então eu juntamos aqui os dois mundos o
ovo tal 0 a 0 trouxe a popularidade e
trouxe a produção e sim organizado na
sua primeira digressão pelo país em 2011
e e aqui está em causa várias crianças
sim ia até digo eu
coisas espetaculares que acontecem este
vil tipo saltar para que everton
adivinho canal é que eu estou muito
raros
mas tem razão para isso
o belo isso resposta cabral entre
pessoas competentes aquelas caras é nós
foi isso foi no ano não era seguir vocês
terem começado todas as escolas é tv e
principalmente a cultura criou um
programa novo que se chama chamava-se
formato cada um era composto por 48
becquerel o navio o cnn.com cá
basicamente esse programa foi
patrocinado pela optimus que precisava
comunicar com o público jovem e nós
tínhamos o público jovem é nossa por nós
próprios jovens quando começávamos mais
pequenos
nós somos melhores mas como quando
começarmos conseguimos comunicar muito
bem com o público jovem e importante foi
uma ótima partida porque nós também
ganhamos muito conhecimento claro a ter
um programa de tv e ótimos conseguiu com
mais eficácia ano caso ocorra a camada
jovem que o senhor teve na altura a
retomarem as escolas começaram a retomar
nós contarmos o chamado programa
pararmos por algum tipo de estrago os
putos gritavam sempre região é nós não
esperamos assim tão antipático
depois vamos retomar de potência foi
criada que basicamente uma um novo
tarifário que ótimo desenvolveu e que
chamou os 11 titulares eram os quatro
chaves para 11
aqui ele é uma pessoa de falta de xuxa
assim roberval e quando voltei a foi uma
nova aventura nós conseguimos envolver
em meus projetos
todos nós temos funções de frente para
mantermos os embaixadores e os caras da
e as caras da marca
temos outras funções aqui a e também é o
nosso maior projeto as coisas até foi o
os rivais
foi um filme que fizemos para o próximo
primeiro país fora obrigado é então o
tfd a oportunidade de poder fazer
projetos mais ambiciosos porque nos
deram diz assim olha se vocês quiserem
fazer 100 nas costas digam nós que temos
nas cenas é então nós queremos fazer uma
coisa que nenhum filme do cinema
é só nós só tínhamos mesma história que
gera vapor caseira sequela do filme
temos feito para 8 bi já também anunciar
evolução numa tal colaboração mas muito
grande um filme bonito porque uma hora e
desta vez tive de fazer isso com ela
só não tenho dinheiro pra fazer um filme
para o cinema não tenhamos material de
cinema ninguém soubesse usar material de
cinema nem tínhamos a vontade por parte
dos meus da luz ao mundo terá um fim eu
posso te dizer é que unidades é normal
os putos que queriam ter um filme sobre
boxe distantes da capital mas bruno
cinema não é é então como é que fizemos
foi só a chery evolution é era
basicamente premiada hotel foi um caso
que o colírio e eram e o filme passou a
ser um conteúdo pelo trf a dívida das
causas da opep nesta altura também
passaram a ser sobre o filme e produziu
o filme ea marca o material de cinema e
as pessoas fomos à universidade losófona
eu sei o curso de cinema e e pessoas que
querem muito trabalhar em cinema e tem o
material nós pedimos emprestado material
e depois da oportunidade de o primeiro
trabalho de eu ser um filme pronto e e
não há em portugal vai ser difícil é a
credibilidade basicamente reserva sofreu
com este e outros foram todos muito fish
e e aceitaram todos entraram no filme
ona jogo mas a do despacho çom muitas
pessoas não só uso mais divertida
oficina e e catarina miranda bronze e
com a ajuda da imagem dele que é muito
mais forte que a nossa e principalmente
na televisão mas os dois não usavam
disseram sem realmente vocês têm que um
filme
muita gente vai prever foi essa nas
letras da pacha cinema quiserem ver o
filme em dvd
é alguns anos depois 300 que em três
anos depois não há um ano depois do
ensaio na hora
o tempo é depois surgiu o toque é que é
um lugar que nós criarmos onde podemos
trabalhar assim maneira mais
profissional é porque nós precisamos que
até gostava de trabalhar uns com os
outros
então aproveitamos isso e vimos as
qualidades de cada um quer que não sabe
fazer mais por exemplo eu tirar um curso
em design e uma das multas por exemplo
sua gestora das redes sociais deus e
essa imposição
eu sou responsável por organizar todas
as saídas do youtube e toda parte produz
ao essas coisas chatas que as manhãs eu
escrevi cenas velha salto alto astral
muito importante um escritório mas não
foi fácil criar eu criei o escritório
isso porque nós não tenhamos um
orçamento para alugar um escritório no
meio do marquês de pombal em lisboa
então o que aconteceu fomos pararam
antigo terminaria hoje carros antigos
trabalham melhor seria outra opção é
adquirir a linha marcha segue morrer
morrer ou de coelhinhos certeza certeza
das melhores imagens estão surgindo e eu
eu tenho nenhum comentário a basicamente
as obras que nós fizemos nós temos mesmo
novas vagas
eu tava pra ver como a 0 o comitê sugere
que sabemos que o que não sabemos é isto
o colete salva que iria porque eu tinha
eu não estava de serviço e está presa
não eu tenho o construtor civil
assombrou muitos gols ano passado então
eu faço com muito vento
pronto é que o pac instante eu sou gecoc
é pro basicamente fizemos o cheiro da
vontade de ter um escritório por
cruzeiro são os outros elementos da
nossa equipe peruana toca e eu estou
pronto o laudo final que é o aula vou a
muitos não sabem não sabe essas
profissionais
claro nós somos nós como ficou mais
bonito sem dúvida
foi então quando aprovamos este espaço
podemos então desenvolver várias funções
e criar outros projetos como o plano de
fuga
acho que é uma série de 11 também de um
amigo nossa ligação com a nossa é e
conseguimos ganhar mais e mais clientes
não é só eu voltei agora já temos mais
assim por exemplo é bill sportzone pela
qual ganhamos um prêmio ela usou de
melhor publicidade delegado gol e eu não
fizer uma gala provoca sobre isto também
que ele vai escalar o clube só tem a
agradecer a google é e volta pra ter
essa foi a nossa intenção é só para
dizer que desde 2011 que nós vamos
pesquisar tudo que nós sabemos que não
sabemos e isso permitiu desenvolver em
escala até aqui é eu não sei onde é que
isto vai ficar
não foi nada fácil não foi nada fácil
começar a fazer tipo a trabalhar num
escritório no início tipo plan brasil
foi tudo é fácil não foi difícil mas não
é impossível por exemplo chegar a horas
o problema é pra eu só lhe buscar chegar
ao escritório ninguém ninguém te dizer o
que têm de fazer e e tu é que tens de
fazer já sabes tu vais fazer o trabalho
não fica assim à espera há coisas que
não está nada diz que os estudantes mas
conseguimos neste momento temos uma top
fish e portanto contrato
e acho que também fiz deixará que a
imagem que 44 nós somos bem amigos que
se juntaram e fizeram os benefícios e as
causas são a opção aos que assim cada
entroncado na rotina mas acho que
tiverem algum projeto ementas devem ir
com isso pra frente por exemplo nós
concluiu
se nós conseguirmos nas costas com cegas
obrigado